[Music]
first announced back on Sony's e3 stage
in 2016 the anticipation for Sonic games
Marvel's spider-man is nothing short of
fever pitch as we draw closer to its
release on September 7 the PlayStation 4
exclusive has a lot to live up to
considering the fervent fan base the web
crawler has both in the comics and pop
culture after spending close to 30 hours
in New York City with Peter Parker and
wonderful cast of supporting characters
Marvel's spider-man is nothing short of
an utterly spectacular adventure that
will entertain for hours on issuing the
traditional origin story Marvel's
spider-man picks up eight years into
Peter Parker's supérieur adventures as
New York's protector he continues to
juggle work school and relationships
things inevitably go arrived in a
friendly neighborhood spider-man takes
to the skies when players go up against
Wilson Fisk aka the kingpin just moments
from the get-go the game establishes
that the sticks are undoubtedly high in
the unfolding story chock full of
memorable figures and familiar faces is
one of the best stories gamers and
comic-book fans will have the pleasure
of partaking in insomnia has put their
own spin on many of the recognizable
members of the spider-man universe
within an old mystery to the familiar
while the well-known names and faces
stay the same the circumstances in which
players meet these individuals will make
audiences see them in a new light
the new narrative presence also serves
to bring a story together in a well
sensational
manner your emotions along with
spider-man's
can expect to be taken for a few twists
and turns yet no matter the
foreshadowing the satisfaction and
impact of the story remains the way
spider-man looks moves
few come close to being perfected in
this game whether you're running up
walls swinging through the skyscrapers
of the city a web sipping around the
freedom of movement is a marvel to
behold forget past spider-man games they
have bought a poor facsimile of the
immaculate system that in songyang is
put in place for many will compare the
combat to the Arkham series there is a
distinct difference in how spider-man
dispatches its force here there is much
more emphasis of fluidity motion speed
and maneuverability as well as the use
of gadgets and various superpowers each
costing post that drastically changes up
the approach to combat as you level up
you are loved new skills that also make
you even more formidable
these are grates allows spider-man to
move even faster hit harder and make
life generally more uncomfortable for
foes instant finishers the ability to
the Sunda enemies and even using their
own rockets against them these upgrades
and more are invaluable in the fight
against new york's criminal empire of
course spider-man has his tools as well
in addition to his combat prowess Peter
Parker packs plenty of gadgets that will
make Tony Stark proud the comparisons do
not stop there as there will be areas
where you need to avoid detection and
take out the criminals quietly
spider-man can web crawl swing and perch
on top of structures to survey the
surrounding
before taking down the unsuspecting
victims by a force stealth or gadgets it
all inevitably results in an all-out
brawl moments later the stealth mode
helps to clean up the numbers
for an bunty there are also certain
stealth sections that star Mary Jane
Watson now an investigative journalist
for The Daily Bugle while the gameplay
mechanics are less complicated than a
combat game reaction and spider-man
these stealth sections are welcome
palate cleanser spliced with a constant
action all the action takes place in the
city of New York which is realized
beautifully the town buildings
intricately designed streets and a many
iconic sights both fictional and in real
life presents a New York City like never
before
while the milling pedestrians could have
new small variety there is no arguing
that this is a definitive version of New
York the players world explore aside
from the main story the open world is
free for players there's film right
after the encounter with a kingpin der
it is a sprawling metropolis with site
activities aplenty
players can search for old backpacks
containing memorabilia and care peda
stories about his early years i'll take
photos of iconic locations and buildings
whether they are tackling random
criminal activities are invading
criminal hideout inclusion of several
surprises will likely bring a smile to
fans faces Peter's job as an intern at a
lab also lets you take on research
projects that require some puzzles to be
solved and the main story is also
complemented by several interesting side
missions that offer not just more XP but
engaging tidbits as well other than
Peter Parker the supporting cast has
been brought to life with great realism
in battle and voice acting and motion
capture of the likes of on main Mary
James Marrs Morales and more more than
do their part in helping sell Marvel's
spider-man as a truly reading world
filled with real people who matter and
it is in these moments a respite from
action that gives the game and almost
cinematic feel in the storytelling from
character moments to choice revelations
the game manages to craft a visual tale
that also melts seamlessly with the
and away the game often transitions from
cutscene to gameplay is simply stunning
every single time it happens yeah any
game no matter how amazing is not
without its issues aside from the
aforementioned repeating crowds and
often times less than inspiring boss
battles combat can sometimes cause the
camera to go crazy and cause it to get
stuck behind environments and below the
surface there were also some lip sync
issues during certain conversations with
quest givers they do not took away from
yogoro experience of course body can
often be isolated incidents but
ultimately every other expect or marvel
spiderman comes extremely close to being
a showcase of a perfect superhero game
and with such a solid foundation laid
down in song and games Marvel's
spider-man is a marvelous start for what
could be a gargantuan franchise for both
Marvel and Sony Playstation in Sonic
games Marvel's spider-man is a
spectacular adventure that combines
comical goodness and gameplay magic the
resulting concoction is a sensational
one that will leave you wanting more
[Music]